lagarde pokrovski est la seule encore
fonctionnel dans la région de donetsk et
ceci est un des derniers trains
d'évacuation de civils de cette partie
du don de bassoues contre l'ukrainien
menacé d'être prise en tenaille par les
troupes russes et elhorga matière le
train est déjà plein cette famille
quitte son domicile pour la seconde fois
à cause de bombardements tout près de
leur maison
ils viennent de quitter ce l'audience
qu'ils aiment et ils ne savent pas où
ils vont aller
cette famille a quitté liman
on nous tiraient dessus
vladimir et le chef du convoi
350 passagers dans ce train cela fait un
mois qu'il évacue des gens de la région
venizia les landes après taxes et frais
bon match jusqu'à 4 5 6 milles par jour
quatre trains par jour
ceux qui embarquent au dernier moment
sont dans cet autobus marqué évacuations
d'enfants ce sont des invalides ou des
handicapés
trois wagons leur sont réservées
l'opération est délicate
pendant le voyage on va demander à
chaque passager où il veut aller qui les
attend quels sont leurs besoins et les
aider s'ils n'ont pas d'endroit où
rester il y à un médecin à bord le
docteur ta race c'est son deuxième
voyage connu jusqu'à
namur mars au dos dans cette invasion
l'ennemi s'en prend aux plus dépourvu il
faut les aider
certains patients sont terrorisés se bat
ses wagons sont spécialement aménagée
pour les handicapés corridors et
toilettes plus vaste quand on demande à
cette dame où elle va elle répond loin
vladimir dit qu'il continuera à convoyer
des gens le temps qu'il faudra il donne
le signal du départ
le train passera d'abord par ni pro où
il embarquera encore des passagers il
prendra la direction de lviv puis de la
frontière polonaise on estime qu'il
reste 25 % de la population dans cette
partie du donbass la plupart sont des
personnes âgées
jean michel leprince sein du canada
pratique